what does a floppy disk a condom with a
magnet a toilet seat filter and a wig
for self-defense all have in common each
of these was invented by Japanese
inventor yoshiro nakamatsu you've
probably never heard of them but
nakamatsu has over 3 300 patents which
is more than any other single person in
history so how exactly does he get so
many ideas he goes underwater diving he
waits till he almost runs out of oxygen
and then he gets inspiration for the new
ideas and then quickly writes them down
on his waterproof memo device but that
isn't even the craziest thing that
nakamatsu does the greatest inventor of
our time winds down every single night
in his 24 karat gold calm room which he
says the gold blocks out radio waves and
television signals that are harmful to
the imagination now that's why